no
[Aplausos]
hoy venimos a romper paradigmas así que
por favor pónganse todos bien
vamos en un pequeño juego
cuando yo aplaudo ustedes van a decir a
rne samsam listos
samsa
podemos aplaudir también a rne samsam
o bien cuando yo diga público le vamos a
hacer molinitos aquí por buddy holly gol
y gol
muy bien cuando yo diga ahora vamos a
una pequeña reverencia así para mí
no
[Música]
te van a hacer un deporte
listo entonces vamos a luego en conjunto
de estos arrancan arrancan angol y holly
holy holy y la ram samsam arrancan está
arrancando un gol y gol y gol y gol y
arranz hasta ahora me hará amigo y holy
holy gol y julián herranz anza
me uní holly holy holy q le arrancan
pero tienen que hacerlo así
[Música]
la dinámica es completa ahora
ninguno más
está
listos
nos encanta estar de poca mano listos 34
am
gol y gol y gol y gol y gol ya rampante
gol y gol y gol y gol y gol y ahora
coli hollywood nicolas rápido
arrancan voleibol y voleibol y goleada
ah
mira mi voleibol y voleibol y con la
raza
mira amigo lee conmigo dijo
bueno
fuercen tarea
así para que sea bonita
o bien cómo se sienten vamos a ver el de
rojo cómo te sientes fuerte felices cómo
te sentiste con esta dinámica
porque tú
[Música]
usted señorita
con esta dinámica
muy bien gracias joven usted
feliz como un niño bueno hay a mi favor
de guardar este sentimiento así luego lo
guardamos equipo
bueno vamos a hablar de eso
bueno
un niño con una guitarra iniciamos
dice la música es para el alma lo que la
gimnasia
para el cuerpo latón que resalta la
importancia de esta frase y cuán
importante es la música para el ser
humano desde tiempos inmemoriales
tenemos la música en nuestra cultura
o cante enamorar a alguien solamente una
vez
pero bueno mi historia inicial es 2010
nuestra ciudad fue secuestrada
fue invadida nos robaron nos robaron la
sonrisa nos bajarán esa tranquilidad
nuestra paz la ciudad entraron paradigma
de miedo social llegamos a hacer la
ciudad más violenta del mundo
y lo más triste todavía es que entramos
en una costumbre nos daba igual
números xy yo
pero bueno yo podría pararme frente a
ustedes y contarles una asociación de
hechos violentos que ha pasado día a día
de tragedias que pasan en nuestra ciudad
pero pero no no es el caso
hoy vengo a compartirles con ustedes una
palabra que se llama resiliencia que es
la resiliencia la resiliencia la
capacidad de un individuo y de un grupo
de superar la adversidad esa capacidad
señoras y señores en la que desarrollan
los alumnos de umbral y los docentes día
a día y ustedes se preguntarán
qué es un gran
que eso me lo va a decir exactamente qué
es sombra umbral es una asociación civil
sin fines de lucro para niños jóvenes
con necesidades tan básicas como el amor
y la paz
la paz
aquí los niños
vienen a jugar bien a reír comparten
aquí estamos compartiendo un pastel en
la colonia tierra nueva
los niños grandes las caras
ay qué niño realmente está como
desfigurado así con el amor
pero es feliz o sea un niño un niño
feliz no puede ser un niño malo
así que otra muy bien mi pregunta es
esta pregunta cómo lo logramos muy fácil
rompiendo paradigmas
y usted dirá que si un loco un utópico
que es imposible yo les aseguro que no
vamos a de otro juego que ya no se van a
tener que parar
tienes ojos por favor pero yo no estoy
viendo a todos los estoy viendo
cerramos los troncos podemos bajar un
poquito lados
disfrutamos de este momento
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cómo se dibujan las dos
[Música]
d
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]
e
i
pero no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vienen colores de colores
vieron formas
vieron campos a lo mejor una trama muy
bien
ahora dígame si todos los que miraron
ahí está exactamente en este salón
no verdad bien así trabaja umbral con
todos los sueños que los niños tienen
como el músico ser aceptado ser
escuchado hoy pertenecer a
sentirse amado todo eso lo hace nuestra
asociación
en menos de un mes pasan de ser y de ser
espectadores
hacer actor es bastante estar viendo un
vídeo de youtube
tocando una guitarra tocamos en plazas
en la plaza de la mexicanidad la
orquesta de ovas de revolución
en el teatro
incluso en chihuahua les damos a este
propósito esa energía de que ellos
pueden un niño chiquito
bailamos jugamos reímos y aquí está la
clave d
de cómo como podemos
a ser mejor en nuestro mundo
quiero romper con ustedes el paradigma
de que la música se aprende con sudor y
lágrimas' borrado de su mente por favor
si no nos vemos a la salida
porque la base del juego
es importantísimo
dice el oliver wendell uno no se hace
uno no deja de jugar porque se hace
viejo no se hace viejo porque dejó jugar
diviertan se rían se salten bueno
[Música]
nosotros vivimos
esta idea en tres fases la primera fase
contrarrestar el paradigma de
mira social
como lo podemos hacer
no sólo basta una clase si ayuda pero no
basta necesitamos una red un apoyo un
soporte como lo hicimos vean esto
ellos son los padres de familia de los
alumnos de un brand
ellos limpian parques limpian pintan
hacen
hacen recaudación de fondos para los
uniformes de los niños andan vendiendo
hamburguesas realmente es una unión
tremenda la que estaba sucediendo en
esta comunidad
segundo la segunda fase es restablecer
el tejido social
nuestros jóvenes salían de la escuela y
que hacen se meten directamente a la
casa y al teléfono a la tablet al
internet
y a horas incalculables en el facebook
el nivel de cultura de vacíos
complicada entonces nosotros tratamos de
restablecer y de ir a estas comunidades
para hacerlo salir junto con sus padres
y sus hermanos y jóvenes y niñas
cuál es la solución
tenemos los problemas aquí bueno hay
muchos pero estos dos tenemos que
nosotros hemos detectado es
romper el paradigma social de mía social
y restablecer el tejido como
por medio de los procesos creativos como
la danza ellas son niñas dancísticas
el teatro
y la música flauta transversal
no crean que es de comer
bueno uno de los momentos que más ha
marcado mi vida dentro del umbral como
docente fue cuando fuimos a cantar al
muro
al bordo de eeuu cruzamos nos metimos
abajo del río
todos ellos son los docentes de umbral y
llegaron más tarde ahorita de sesión de
fotos llegaron más tarde los padres y
los alumnos estuvo interesante porque
porque está en brasil donde políticos
nos quieren dividir entonces de un lado
estamos la asociación civil umbral y del
otro lado están las asociaciones civiles
de san elizario nos juntamos así frente
de frente divididos por un muro
y cantamos 'cielito lindo'
se los juro que se pudiera hacer que
sintieran la emoción que yo sentí yo
llorarían como yo lo hice en ese momento
estar viendo y unidos por dos dos más
dos países por un solo canto
ay ay ay ay me canta y no llores por qué
[Música]
ellos son los padres de familia y van
rumbo al
rumbo al muro fue algo épico aquí
ellos mis alumnos de la rondalla de vida
colonial en la que pertenezco en la que
me des logrado desenvolver
lo importante que quiero rescatar de
esta fotografía es que muchos decimos
que quiero cambiar el mundo el mundo y
yo yo quiero cambiar este romper ese ese
molde y decir no quiero cambiar el mundo
quiero cambiar su mundo porque es el
mundo de ellos los que está a 20
afectados yo puedo decir no contribuyas
y muchas cosas por el mundo pero no
cambien el mundo de las personas que
aman que quieren yo doy mi vida también
por ellos porque han sido parte
fundamental de mi crecimiento como
docente y aquí
un atrás
y aquí está
tenemos un gas muy especial llegó hace
cuatro años a umbral tenía 17 años y
como todo joven de 17 años tienes dudas
tienes miedo no saben a dónde a dónde ir
de 17 años quería ser ingeniero nuclear
llegó hace 4 años
y lo único que quería hacer lo único que
sabía era que quería tocar la guitarra y
de aprender a tocar la guitarra porque
cuando llegó agarro al revés
así digo ahí el arco no dejen de llevar
entonces
le dimos la guitarra
[Música]
y él se encargó de aprender la verdad
que fue un inundó estudió música y
actualmente es taxista de umbral
ohl obtuvo un propósito tuvo una meta
actualmente tiene dos núcleos es pasó de
ser como le digo es el alumno
hacer maestro a ser compañero
ok estas son algunas de las experiencias
que quisieron compartir alumnos de la
colonia proletaria
en chihuahua
el siguiente es una madre de familia muy
rápido dígame tenemos hasta las ocho
y este es el caso de un muchacho que nos
gusta estar no quiso ser nombrado es
anónimo
y es aquí en donde yo me refiero a
cambiarse un mundo
nosotros no sabemos el peso
que traen nuestros jóvenes a nuestros
niños y más en esta ciudad
con un libro como ander o con un abrazo
con una sonrisa podemos cambiar la idea
de la mujer que ella trier no la voy a
dar a mejorar de caer y de repente y
llegamos si podemos salvar eso
no solo hablo por mí yo estoy respaldado
por todos los analistas que ven aquí por
más educadores que están y que ya no
están
hablo por ellos y hablo por el amor que
le tenemos a méxico y hablo por el amor
tenemos a nuestra ciudad
muy bien rescatemos
el sentimiento a nuestra sele mañana
ya que en su sentimiento del principio
por favor
pero menos aquellos
muy bien
señoras y señores este sentimiento que
ustedes tienen en su mano es lo que hace
volver a los niños día a día son el
sentimiento de felicidad de emoción de
aprender algo nuevo ese sentimiento es
el que hace que se levanten temprano y
le digan a su papá
ellos impulsan al papá es lo que voy es
que temprano entonces ellos bailan
ellos cantan
es una presentación de la rodadora
increíble un niño alcanzando notas
ya podemos que la mano
así
soy bien
ok
[Música]
ustedes se preguntarán
porque encendió una vela
esta vela
significa la luz
[Música]
que pudimos con la que pudimos darnos
cuenta de las necesidades
de nuestros niños y jóvenes de nuestra
comunidad
ahora esta luz si las comparto a ustedes
para que se la compartan a otros ya
otros a partir de ahora eso de ver
compartir esta luz para
y hacer de este mundo un mundo mejor
y recuerden un niño con una guitarra es
un adulto común a un niño con una
guitarra es un adulto - con un arma